welcome to hannity we begin with what is
really a chilling fox news alert in
moments by the way the 45th president of
the united states donald trump he will
join us live on camera to respond to the
gut-wrenching disaster that is now
unfolding inside afghanistan as 10 000
plus
american citizens are trapped inside the
country and we see no immediate plan to
get them out as joe biden has been
asleep at the wheel for days we expect
oh he might momentarily arrive back from
his vacation at the white house we'll
ask president trump about his prior
negotiations direct negotiations with
the taliban and the red lines that he
put in place
that joe biden clearly did not enforce
president trump coming up exclusively
meanwhile tonight joe biden finally
coming back from camp david and gearing
up for what is i guess a restful night
at the white house while thousands of
our fellow americans are living through
hell on earth in afghanistan we cannot
even report to you tonight the exact
number of americans that are trapped
inside afghanistan somewhere we're told
reports between 10 000 and maybe as many
as forty thousand of our fellow
americans are trapped behind enemy lines
spread out all over the country we don't
know where they all are the bid
administration doesn't know exactly how
many they don't know where these
americans are located and now biden's
state department is just telling them
just shelter in place and when notified
find your own way to the airport in
kabul
please tell me that's not your plan
you guys are not serious according to
biden's clueless national security
adviser the terrorists in the taliban
will now that they're in control provide
safe passage this as taliban fighters
are now savagely beating shooting
stabbing people all around the airport a
foreign correspondent with the la times
tweeted out these horrific images
showing the taliban using gunfire whips
sticks sharp objects to attack those on
airport road according to one u.s
official quote the taliban have a ring
outside of the airport they won't let
anyone inside it and the big issue here
is that no people outside of the taliban
ring will get in
no way they get thirty thousand not even
close over the weekend we saw these
images of a us military plane packed
with 600 plus people
desperately fleeing kabul but now planes
are taking off mostly empty why because
the taliban is not allowing passage into
the airport one german plane capable of
carrying 150 individuals yeah they took
off with seven passengers on board and
meanwhile taliban terrorists they're
going now door to door according to
numerous reports tonight searching for
americans allies and american
interpreters and anyone else who they
believe assisted the u.s in any way over
the last 20 years there are horrifying
reports of people being tortured
dismembered and executed in the streets
across the country according to the
washington post wow when would they ever
agree with sean hannity u.s citizens are
now reaching out to anyone and everyone
back in washington for help the biden
administration must get moving on a plan
to rescue them
before it's too late tonight we all as a
country
we need to pray to god that it's not too
late with every passing hour and every
passing day we grow closer and closer to
what could be a possibly a mass hostage
situation or worse the murder of
americans on a colossal scale the number
one priority of the bite administration
when joe finally gets back he hasn't
quite arrived yet must be the safe of
actual evacuation of every american but
as we speak
at this hour there's no plan to rescue
our fellow citizens let alone our allies
let alone the translators that were
promised by our government that if this
moment ever came they would be protected
by us and other afghans that face
certain death because of their
assistance to our country in the last 20
years there is no plan whatsoever
there's nothing and even worse the biden
administration won't even commit to
securing the airport past august the
31st even if fellow americans are
trapped inside the country
this i had to see for myself i will let
you decide
can you
offer any guarantee to the americans and
afghan allies that if they remain there
past the end of the month u.s troops
will help them evacuate we'll pass the
end of the month
our our focus right now is undoing the
work at hand and on the task at hand and
that is day by day getting as many
american citizens as many siv applicants
as many members of a vulnerable
population who are eligible to be
evacuated to the airport and out on
planes and we're going to do that in
expeditious fashion that is the focus of
the president of our secretary of
defense of our secretary of state and
everybody on our national security team
uh so that that is where we will keep
our efforts
joe biden and jen sake they had ignored
this for three straight days as they
both been on vacation our defense
secretary our secretary of state the
vice president and all of the national
security advisers seemed totally
clueless and oblivious to what was
unfolding before the world's eyes to see
to be clear the biden administration is
making zero promises tonight if you're
afraid for your life and you are in
afghanistan and somehow seeing this show
whether you're an american or one of our
allies you have good reason to feel that
way if you're a journalist whose life is
at risk tonight like every other
american joe biden has no plan for you
either and none of this
is is political any anyway
i don't care what news organization i
don't care why you're there who you work
for you're a fellow american every good
decent american we want you all home
safely but for whatever reason joe biden
just didn't seem to care didn't seem to
understand the magnitude as this was
unfolding in record time when he told us
this wouldn't happen
if you're a little girl tonight and you
live in afghanistan well the odds are
higher that you will be enslaved by the
taliban
joe biden takes zero responsibility as
we saw yesterday he's either heartless
or completely checked out you decide
until a few hours ago joe biden hadn't
even spoken to not a single world leader
about the fall of kabul and the
situation unfolding in afghanistan not a
single other world leader keep in mind
biden was warned over and over and over
again marco rubio told us last night
that his strategy for withdrawal would
end in this disaster marco rubio and
others democrat and republican senators
on the intel committee have been warning
biden and his administration repeatedly
they have been ignored repeatedly joe
biden's top generals according to
numerous reports were pleading with him
to slow the draw down to conditions that
were based on the ground when they were
conducive because they're not conducive
right now for what's happening now this
is the single largest military intel
debacle i've ever seen in my life and
i've seen a number of them and as this
crisis is unfolding biden could only be
bothered to put his vacation on pause
for a short what 10-minute scripted
speech where he blamed everybody for
this disaster and then said the buck
stopped with him then turned around and
went right back on vacation or as the
wall street journal editorial board well
quite eloquently put it biden to
afghanistan and the americans there
dropped dead biden is literally defiant
in blaming others for his afghan debacle
even one former cia analyst i couldn't
believe my eyes on ms dnc was outraged
and rightly so take a look
this consequential speech by the
american president didn't run from it he
owned it he owned his decision he owned
the fact that as he put it the buck
stops with him
i hope he gets to hone their deaths too
i i don't i feel like i watched a
different speech than the rest of you
guys i was appalled and the idea that
the afghan military should be blamed for
this do you know how many casualties the
afghan military took in an average year
more than the united states did in 20
when you're not getting paid on a
regular basis when you're not getting
fuel when no one is supplying you with
ammunition and yet you're still showing
up to the fight how dare us for having
to blame these people for not having the
audacity to be able to survive a taliban
onslaught we promised them that in their
time of need we would take care of them
how do you ever expect anyone to ever
trust us again if we don't do that now
while we can
joe biden has destroyed america's
credibility around the world and tonight
actually that's the least of our worries
china and russia they're already looking
to cut deals with the new islamic
emirates as it will be called of
afghanistan run by the terrorists
supporting taliban terrorists from al
qaeda will now have again a safe haven
in afghanistan once again just two
decades after 9 11 2001 and get this the
reported mastermind behind the taliban
takeover this ought to get you blood
boiling yeah we had him in custody he
was a prisoner at guantanamo bay we had
him we had no reason to release him but
he was released in a swap you might
remember for army deserter bo bergdahl
during the obama biden administration
and if you recall at the time they both
assured all of us in america that they
were going to qatar and would never
return to afghanistan or terrorism ever
again but don't worry according to the
biden administration all americans can
trust this terrorist to now give them
safe passage to the airport that they
now have created a perimeter around and
not allowing anyone to get through the
one that's currently surrounded the one
that embassy workers were airlifted into
joe biden this country just days ago
none of this would happen how could he
be so wrong that's a question we'll be
asking for a long time take a look
is the taliban takeover of afghanistan
now inevitable no
it is not why
because you have the afghan troops have
300 000
well-equipped as well as quipped as any
army in the world
and an air force
against something like 75 000 taliban
it is not inevitable there's going to be
no circumstance where you see people
being lifted off the roof
of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan
now this is a disaster at a massive
scale there's no end in sight president
trump as i told you is moments away will
get his take how will we deal with this
from now hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else